welcome back to the David Pakman show
I'm fair and cousins sitting in for
David today David has a speaking
engagement and hopefully the clip of
that is going to be available on
youtube.com slash mid-week politics
sometime in the very near future I don't
know if you've been paying attention to
some of the goings-on with the actual
Republican Party itself over the last
few weeks but this week in particular we
have seen some absolute I don't want to
call it insanity but it kind of reads a
lot like insanity
Steve Bannon you know former member of
the Trump administration now back at
Breitbart his website breitbart.com has
published an article in the last few
days talking about how Bannon and this
new version of the Republican Party is
attempting to take over Republican
politics here in the United States
bannon's plan is that he wants to run
far-right conservatives
essentially alt-right conservatives to
challenge
almost every sitting Republican that
does not fit in to the Bannen model of
politics which includes Mitch McConnell
Senate Majority Leader Bannon is
essentially on a crusade at this point
he wants to remake the Republican Party
in his image and now that's a scary
thought we know what Steve Bannon stands
for we know he is all about the
alt-right we know there's some white
supremacy leanings among those people
and that's what Bannon wants Bannon is
upset right now with the current
incarnation of the Republican Party in
the makeup of the House and Senate he's
upset because they're not doing enough
to push this country further to the
right he's angry that we don't have that
wall yet he's angry
were not having mass deportations at the
moment he's angry that people are still
allowed to come across the border he's
mad at the Republican Party for this now
Bannon personally and Donald Trump there
doesn't appear to really be too much
friction there I know after Bannon was
let go or resigned or whatever actually
happened behind the scenes there there
was a lot of talk that Bannon might be
the guy to actually take down the Trump
administration because he's the guy that
knows everything unfortunately it's kind
of gone the other way Bannon and Trump
are still buddy-buddy neither of them
has come out against the other and
instead they're working to remake the
Republican Party and Bannon has all
kinds of plans that have been laid out
recently to launch these challenges to
Republicans as they approach reelection
in 2018 however establishment
Republicans I guess we can call them or
moderate Republicans in some cases
they're not exactly happy about this
because they understand what it means
for the Republican Party because all
they have to do for evidence is look at
what Donald Trump has done to the
Republican Party now that's the other
side of this coin here
while Steve Bannon wants to take the
party further to the right make them
more extreme elect dozens of little
Donald Trump's and offices all over the
country actual Republicans Republicans
who care about their party or at least
pretend to they have been coming out and
warning in the past week or so the
Donald Trump is absolutely destroying or
threatening to destroy by his words and
actions the modern incarnation of the
Republican Party Michael Steele former
chairman of the RNC came out just a few
days ago and said what Donald Trump is
doing as president threatens the future
of the Republican Party joe scarborough
MSNBC host former republican congressman
said that destroying the GOP is actually
going to be Trump's legacy and what's
interesting here is that
there's a bit of a disconnect I think
between sitting Republicans and the
Steve Bannon types because let's be
perfectly honest about what's happening
within the Republican Party today there
is not a single policy there is not a
single thing that Donald Trump has done
or pledged to do that the Republican
Party itself has not already attempted
to do in the past the wall idea between
the United States and Mexico that wasn't
Donald Trump's invention he's not clever
enough for that Republican politicians
have been proposing a wall for years
it's always been a fringe you know a guy
that probably could never get elected or
nobody ever took seriously proposing
these things but they have been proposed
beyond that when we look at things like
tax reform there's absolutely no
difference between what Donald Trump
wants to do and what the Republican
establishment like mcconnell and paul
ryan want to do there in that together
they're all on the same page on tax
reform health care they want to repeal
the Affordable Care Act Trump came out
today with an executive order trying to
unwind that they're all on the same page
they don't care if 22 or 32 depending on
which version of their horrible bill
that they're on now 32 million people go
without health insurance or get kicked
off their plans because we repeal the
subsidies that help them pay for it or
because their plans themselves get
jacked up in price or if they get
excluded for pre-existing conditions
they don't care but what's important is
that they really are all on the same
page here so when you hear people like
Michael Steele talking about Donald
Trump's destroying the Republican Party
or Joe Scarborough saying they were
destroying the Republican Party or we
want to we want Mitch McConnell to
resign as some conservative leaders are
saying today keep in mind there's no
difference in policy between any of
these people Joe Scarborough himself is
one that infuriates me more than any
because yeah he's done a good job in the
last few months talking out against
Trump good for him
he helps set the Republican Party on
this path back when he was a congressman
in the 1990s in fact he was a
congressman in my district I was too
young to vote at the time otherwise I
would have voted against him but
Scarborough helped with the contract for
America he wanted to privatize the
Department of Education he wanted to
privatize other governmental departments
sound familiar because it's pretty much
what Republicans still want today the
Republican Party has not changed all
Donald Trump has done is come out and
help expose what they actually stand for
what they actually want to do so I don't
believe for a minute the people like
Michael Steele or Joe Scarborough are
truly upset that Donald Trump is
destroying the party because at the end
of the day the policies that Trump has
proposed are no different from policies
we have seen from Republicans for the
last 20 or 30 years